foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to the Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong podcast it's your girl
Jacqueline back for another wet hot
episode
with my Summer favorite
I'm American
we got all four words in the title in
there that's Jacqueline I'm Mark Ellis
and I am so excited to talk about a
movie that again this is I told our
guest today that I was gonna let him
down in some regard and instantly
everybody's mind is going to go to well
you didn't like the movie that I'm
coming on here to stop for it's not that
at all it's that this movie was released
in 2001 and I saw this movie for the
first time last night oh and given my
history with the folks involved given my
Adoration of their comedic Talent since
the mid 90s and a certain sketch show on
MTV it's nothing short of criminal I
should be prosecuted for not having seen
this film before now but
am I glad I did we'll talk about it yeah
of course ladies and gentlemen this
episode this week we're talking about
wet Hot American Summer the cult classic
from 2001 and it was rated 20 sorry 38
rotten on the Tomato Meter but a 75 that
would be a certified fresh audience
score if we had one we have a guest here
today who I think is probably the
perfect person to do this because it is
a parody satire film and this man
literally makes a living doing that
along with other things of course I'm
talking about Mr law and Harris writer
and co-host of the binge boys podcast he
joins us today Lon I will go ahead and
say it give me your wet hot take I'm
sorry I just really want to say it every
time
what hot take on is Rotten Tomatoes
wrong on wet Hot American Summer first
of all welcome to the podcast thank you
good to be here great to be in studio
sitting across you in person I know you
have legs yeah I love this movie I love
this movie for a long time I was a big
fan of the state as you alluded to uh I
was a big fan of that on MTV so I would
David Wayne Michael Showalter these guys
were very much on my radar in 2001. I
don't think I saw this in theaters
though I think I caught up with this
like once it hit video uh DVD I guess in
that I remember coming out I don't
remember it was a very limited like
indeed basically like they they went to
festivals and he thought it was gonna
you know get picked up and it didn't it
really didn't so USA films ended up
after Fest it's Festival run kind of
bought it from him for like 100k or some
insultingly low offer and it barely came
out in theaters yeah because people
compare it a lot of times to other cold
comedy Classics like for example office
space it came out around the same time
and you had the MTV shared DNA with my
judge making office space but office
space had an ad campaign and it was
released in theaters I remember seeing
the ads for with the oh face guys yeah
same thing see I didn't see that in
theaters either at least I was aware of
it with wet Hot American Summer it's and
we'll talk about it it's just it's the
perfect sort of Comedy that you put on
when you and all your friends come back
home from whatever right maternity party
you try to get into that night in
college and you just watch it on repeat
night after night after night and I
missed it and I'm mad because this is
exactly the kind of movie that I would
have loved and I saw it for the first
time this morning and I guess I'll kick
off the festivities by saying Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong with that 38 so I was
just I would just say I did not have the
viewing experience that either one of
you had
the movie uh the baseball movie that
starred Blake Jenner like everybody
wants them everybody
so we were doing a compilation listicle
of teen comedy sort of like uh like
summer movie like American Pie this is
like one of those like great like all in
one day movies like it's got that Dazed
and Confused Vibe where it's all one day
and overnight yeah and so we were
basically compiling a list of these sort
of like summer teen uh Ensemble movies
and that one was one of the ones that we
do in there and so that's when I first
saw this so it wasn't that long ago
whatever that movie came out maybe five
or six years ago that I finally watched
this one and
I mean is it 38 wrong no but it's still
pretty rotten like I'm sorry I'm so
sorry I laughed at this movie I had such
a fun amount of time with this movie but
it is definitely not a movie that I'm
like oh yeah this holds up this is funny
like everybody in this I'll I'll talk
about it later I don't think Rotten
Tomatoes is that wrong I think the
wrongish I know y'all love me saying
that but my main thing is is that this
movie has literally like the dream team
of Comedy oh yeah like legitimately the
most comedic genius Minds out there and
if you're the director of this all you
have to do is give a premise point and
shoot and to me you should be walking
into an academy
screenplay worth of comedy and it wasn't
that and so this movie is funny and it's
great but it's almost sort of like the
reverse Simone biles what else were you
gonna be with that much talent like the
fact that it wasn't like a masterpiece
I'm like looking at you kind of
side-eyed like Judd Apatow has made a
career career of doing this and has
gotten way more credit I think we're
being a writer just by the fact that he
always hires writers I love you reaming
this movie like that you're like you
should have won an Olympic gold medal
but instead you were smoking dope with
your friends outside the training just
like the movie is meant to be it is yeah
and it's like dog paddling in the kiddie
pool thank you but even if it's good dog
paddling it's not like you should be
come on yeah but there's a lot about
what whether this movie I guess achieved
the goal that it was going for versus
what you would consider to be a normal
Slice of Life team comedy so there's a
lot to get into it yeah we're only like
pound for pound it's funnier than any of
those like jet appetizers it's maybe not
as accomplished like in terms of a piece
of filmmaking I'm just a joke for joke
scene for scene I think you're saying
Rotten Tomatoes are stronger oh you're
saying it's wrong I'm saying not really
if you really consider all the facts
that's what I'm saying but we have
plenty to statistically holistically
whatever when we get to it we will I
think when we look at all the evidence
all together we will make it that I am
probably right but I want to give a
quick shout out to you
the 150 essential comedy movies to watch
right now on Rotten Tomatoes please
check it out as well as if you haven't
already check out the entry that we have
a wet Hot American Summer in our book
Rotten movies we love we kind of have an
idea of where we all stand on this I'm
going to try and not pretend like I'm a
puppet as we transition over to our
favorite segment two mints with Tim
let's say you're a film critic and the
year is 2001 and you've just seen Wet
Hot American Summer either at Sundance
or just before it's theatrical release
you are not watching a cult classic you
can't be sure if any of the actors will
go on to become Stars you certainly
don't know that many of your friends
will be trading quotes from this movie
20 years from now or that there will be
events around the country to celebrate
the anniversary of its release or that
there will be two spin-off series and a
making of documentary on Netflix a
company that currently only rents DVDs
by mail and it's more than a decade away
from creating its own content you don't
know that this movie is eventually going
to be someone's favorite movie no you
can't know any of these things because
you are watching a new movie and you
have a deadline to meet I bring all this
up because every once in a while I'll
meet someone who insists that the
critics were wrong about wet Hot
American Summer but it's not like it was
initially a huge hit with audiences
either it had some Buzz at Sundance but
according to Box Office Mojo it made
less than three hundred thousand dollars
during its theatrical run I always try
to remind people that no one not even
film critics can successfully predict a
film's historical reputation after one
viewing and that's especially true of
Wet Hot American Summer a small movie
that looks like a goofy Lark at the time
but built up a feverish cult over the
course of years Wet Hot American Summer
is rotten at 38 on the Tomato Meter with
76 reviews and it has a 75 audience
score so what did the critics have to
say
in a rotten review Bruce Westbrook of
the Houston Chronicle wrote for all its
failings wet hot maintains energy and
High Spirits over most of its length the
trouble is such energy and Spirits are
not infectious and the movies it mocks
were better however in a fresh review
owned gliber men of Entertainment Weekly
called it a loving and meticulous
Recreation of the last moment before
American youth culture went permanently
ironic the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus reads wet hot American
Summer's incredibly talented cast is too
often outmatched by a deeply silly
script that misses its targets at least
as often as it skewers them so that's
Wet Hot American Summer Jacqueline Mark
let's all promise that in 10 years from
today we'll meet again and we'll see
what kind of people we've blossomed into
or maybe I'll just see you folks at the
office back to you
way to go Tim I love this review that's
technically a rotten review from Michael
Atkinson of the Village Voice because I
I kind of feel like it paints both sides
of the aisle here it's a comedy without
a map it will be loathed but it might be
ahead of its time so maybe you could say
that about wet Hot American Summer yeah
I mean I definitely think that even if
you're panning a movie if you are a
study or a film history you can't
predict it but you can definitely be
like this has cult classic Vibes you
know what I mean like this has yeah like
I I saw the trailer for Megan and I was
like I don't know if this is gonna make
money but somebody's gonna live for this
you know you're probably gonna sing
Titanium
exactly everybody's gonna go nuts
exactly and this is going to be
something that people watch over and
over again yeah sometimes I feel like
people just put that label on a movie
like it could be a cult classic because
they don't know what else to do with it
but this I mean we'll talk about it but
I feel like this has a lot of different
that there's straight comedy in this and
then there's just complete spoof comedy
and then there's winking and not there
is a lot of irony there is a just a lot
of ridiculousness there's just a lot of
stupidity but it just it all it's a stew
yeah it's a comedic stew with a lot of
ingredients I think the one thing I
would add is I like teach me teaching
very very fair to critics and I think
that that's good but I think the one
thing is that you would add is it's not
like spoof movies ever really got their
due like I feel like always even at the
peak the height of the parody movie
phenomenon it was always kind of like a
you know like sort of stepchild genre
that critics always kind of dumped on
even like I remember as a kid when Naked
Gun two and a half came out and I was
like it was like the movie that was the
top of my list I was so excited the
funniest of the three yeah I mean I
loved Frank driving I loved that stuff
and like the all the reviews were kind
of sad they're like that's mediocre some
of the jokes work some of them don't and
so I feel like there's always kind of a
problem with this genre where it's just
it's not critics favorite I mean yes and
no because it depends they just they
like who they like in that genre if you
make yourself a parody artist I think
it's like you can do it like because Mel
Brooks is he's been Banger after Banger
you know what I mean even I mean like
but by the time you got this the
Spaceballs era which I think my favorite
one of my favorites of his but that
movie got dumped it feels like you had a
handful of spoof movies that came out in
the 70s and 80s not even tossed like a
doctor Strangelove in there where you
have Mel Brooks and then you have
Blazing Saddles and like the zombies
then you had airplane in 1980 and it
feels like critics just stamped those
all is these are the spoof Classics and
then nothing else could ever follow it
even if a movie like top secret I think
is funnier yeah than airplane
like Hot Shots I think it's hysterical
but it just doesn't do it when Black
Dynamite blew up at I think it was
Sundance or one of the festivals and
like even that like that's one of the
best parody movies ever freaking made
and even that one didn't get like a huge
upsurge of critics behind it like you
had to kind of find that one on your own
so I like I always feel like these
movies are overlooked no matter how good
or bad they are I think with parody with
anything I think what I will talk about
this if you have familiarity with what's
being parodied it's going to be
something and I will just say by the
time we're getting to things like wet
Hot American Summer and Spaceballs
you're already parroting things that a
lot of these people didn't necessarily
have the emotional resonance to sure the
first time around as you start to
progress around and I think that is
really what what ends up happening
because yeah the parody of gangsters
paradise for me is is always gonna like
that Weird Al song is gonna hit harder
because of how much I played Gangsters
Paradise you know what I mean Amish
Paradise versus Gangster's Paradise I'm
sorry I don't have the same emotional
resonance to American Pie with Don
McLean like the fact that you did the
Yoda story with that one doesn't hit as
hard for me like I don't care about you
know so I think it's a little bit of
that let's dive into that as well as
some of our favorite moments favorite
cameos this again is a very stacked cast
as we transition over into our movie
talk section
foreign
so I think with this one before we dive
deep into the existential of it because
this is another one of these movies
that's like you know we're talking about
it and I don't think anybody the week
that it came out the weekend of uh 2001
would we think we'd be talking about it
10 years later let alone 22 years later
so what do you think about this film
sort of like rose above all of the other
things to sort of bring it into this
cult classic uh sort of like
categorization yeah I think I think Mark
kind of touched on it there's a certain
kind of Ensemble comedy like these often
get sort of labeled as stoner movies but
I don't think you necessarily need to be
a stone or two like this kind of movie
I'm sure it probably helps it helps you
can always help I mean it helps with any
kind of movie but uh I think where it's
it's a fun movie to put on when you've
got friends over it's it's a movie where
it's less about the the plot that you
like you know you got to get into that
narrative but it's right you like
hanging out with the characters in that
world Dazed and Confused to me maybe
like the the greatest example of this
genre of all time of a movie I just like
to throw on be because I just enjoy
those people and like hanging out with
them in their world and I think this is
very much a familiar there and like
especially because the cast is so sexy
no matter when you you could drop out
you could drop back in and here's a
funny beat with Elizabeth Banks and bull
rider here's a funny thing that uh Chris
Maloney is doing unexpectedly I think
watching this movie I think is how
non-sports fans treat a Super Bowl party
where they're like yeah look it's
exciting I'll I'll drift in and out of
the game if it's good at the end I'll be
paying attention I'm here for the
commercials but I'm here for the event
I'm just here to like hang and if I get
a couple good scenes then I'm happy this
is the kind of movie like a Dazed and
Confused where you put it on and you
don't necessarily have to watch it start
to finish because you've seen it beat by
beat and I'm and I'm saying this is the
guy who first saw this movie this
morning
it's not like threads that get pulled
like oh if you missed that part you're
not gonna like it's it's almost like a
collection of sketches in some ways
which makes sense because it's a sketch
comedy Yeah the more you will this movie
into being a normal structured film the
less you're gonna exactly can't happen
because to your point you can label the
stoner movie but to me I think a lot of
people put the label stoner movie onto
anybody who is going to be who's gonna
respond to this movie who isn't sitting
in the front of the classroom because
like I wasn't a stoner in high school I
laughed at all that stuff right I didn't
I wasn't actively getting high but I
still had that comedic sensibility that
a little bit of resisting Authority I
loved this genre five years before I had
ever ingested a single drugs you don't
have to rebellious whatever it's Teen
Angst it's rebellious tanks that is
either either sort of being performed in
hypersexuality or hyper violence or you
know liking certain types of music that
is very contradictory to your parents or
being like really crude and really Brash
with your friends and your level of
comedy and I think this all sort of like
plays into it but do you think do you
think this one in particular had
something because there was a there was
a bubble up afterwards and I don't think
it was just the hangout do you think it
was the cast itself as they became
bigger do you think it was some I would
say is there like a memorable scene that
everyone sort of like had to be like if
you're putting it on if I'm putting on
Dazed and Confused and being like look
at Matthew McConaughey you know what I
mean like I want you to see this
Woodward guy I want you to see this uh
party they throw right because nobody in
the cast necessarily blew up overnight
right when this came out I mean Bradley
Cooper's in it but again this is 2001
and he didn't really get a lot of heat
until after Wedding Crashers and even
then it wasn't until the hangover in
what 2007 sort of the same trajectory as
like a Paul Rudd and Elizabeth Banks
folks like that so you knew some folks
from SNL you had Molly Shannon Amy
poeler who were getting big from SNL but
again you you can't tell the story of
Wet Hot American Summer without going
back to MTV's sketch of the state which
is the mid 90s it hit right when I was
in high school and I'm watching it and
it's Michael Showalter it's David Wayne
who directed the movie um
Ken Moreno
so seeing them in anything I was like oh
this is this is now my radar I'm going
to like this movie because it had them
in it and so in the same way that I
think a lot of people would revisit this
movie or maybe come to it the first time
because hey I'm a huge Paul Rudd fan I
love the 40 year old virgin and I saw
this funny guy I want to go back and see
what else he's in that was me you know
thinking this could be a great movie
simply because it has folks from a show
that I loved the state and then also the
SNL doesn't doesn't hurt it at all I
also think there's there's a sweetness
to this that a lot of these kinds of
teen movies or stoner movies or whatever
there's like it's it's that American Pie
it's that crude it's that crude braunce
humor which it has its place and I like
it and can be fun but I think this movie
kind of undercuts that a lot and and
makes that the joke like there's that
scene where the guys find out that
Bradley Cooper and Michael Lee and
Black's characters are gay and at first
it looks like it's going to become like
a a gay bashing kind of they're gonna
they're gonna bully them but then they
buy them a chains Lounge at Crate and
Barrel with like a housewarming gift and
it it takes the sweetest yeah warmest
possible turn and I think that's kind of
Showalter and Wayne's sensibility just
generally and I think that that comes
through so nicely in this and it does
make it a more a fun kind of alternative
to some of the other kind of team movies
that are more focused on like getting
laid and like you know beating up the
kids from the other camp or like
whatever the more and camping generally
sort of is here I mean you know before
we were all hanging out with our friends
necessarily but by choice we're like hey
what's all let's all meet at this place
because we all want to go there a lot of
kids went to camp and that was what you
did during the summer and whether you
loved it whether you hated or whether
you had a romance whether you never got
to first base with anybody you still
have that kind of shared memory of what
camp was like either as being a kid
there or being a counselor and so
there's there's a lot of Americana baked
into this premise too because as soon as
I put the movie on I'm like okay half of
this is trying to pay homage to Bill
Murray's meatballs and half of this is
sort of spoofing meatballs which is sort
of tied into the fact that Paul Rudd is
reading a rolling stone that has Bill
Murray on the cover and the the the
movie The Move that this film did right
at the beginning the telegraph this is
not like a traditional Camp comedy this
is going to be winking and nodding and
making fun of itself and being
self-referential and being
self-deprecating all the same time was
the first kiss that you see between Paul
Rudd and yeah who's this girl it's uh
Marguerite Moreau yeah
sloppy full of tongue no whip kiss
they're basically just licking each
other's tongues and right there you're
like I know what this move at least me I
was like I know what tone this movie's
going for and then Ken Moreno shows up
for the first time right after that and
I'm like I love everything this movie's
doing I'm sorry I'm just getting
disgusted by that kiss again because I'm
visualizing it and I'm just like oh
your face is wet after that like your
face is wet and cold yeah and they're
hot breath it's like and apparently
every day during filming this movie it
rained so I figured
it was a wet summer but it was
definitely
everything looks so overcast it was like
Marquee because they had the shoe before
the camp actually functioned as a camp
so uh yeah it was it was definitely wet
I definitely want to add this one also
into that so I definitely know what
Michael Showalter did again another
little thing he not he uh the
oscar-nominated script uh the big sick
starring Emily V Gordon a friend of both
vars
which was the Jessica Chastain so he's
he's gotten people to the Oscars a few
times since here which I think is crazy
what's David Wayne like I did not know
what he got into after this because he
definitely seemed to make this very much
his well he did uh they came together
that Paul writing me polar one which is
like kind of a spiritual follow-up to
this one I I would love to see him do
more like I wish he was just like I
really wondered about him because I know
show Walter sort of blew up and most a
lot of those TV stuff yeah Wayne feels
like one of those guys who punches up
every script yeah I feel like he does
too let's have David Wayne do it whether
it's a big comic book movie or whether
it's an Indy let's make sure David Wayne
gets his eyes on this it sort of feels
like that Stella is the other one we
haven't mentioned he and and Showalter
and Michael Ian Black were in a really
great comedy troupe together Post State
called Stella that had like a Comedy
Central it was comedy centralized yeah
uh that was this it was like this kind
of like it had a plot like there was a
sitcom and they were roommates and there
were stories but it was absurd totally
absurd and
um added to there let me get to my
Simone biles of it all okay this cast
yeah look okay Amy Poehler Bradley
Cooper Elizabeth Bank Christopher
Maloney Molly Shannon Ken Moreno Joe
tarulo Michael Ian Black not to mention
uh Marguerite Moreau Paul Rudd and
Michael Showalter Jenny Garofalo David
Hyde Pierce all those names
there's a lot of guys that you'd
recognize like A.D miles is one of the
day like yeah were there as soon as you
see them you're like that guy I know
from Comedy Bang Bang or from this show
or from sketches in this or from this
you know comedy like a lot of faces
you'll recognize from the world of
Comedy even if you don't know them it's
part of the trait of re-watching it for
a lot of folks and for me seeing it the
first time some 20 odd years later is
that there are those moments where it's
like oh I like him yeah or I like her so
now I'm gonna like this scene but I try
not to let that affect my viewing of
this movie given my Affinity for the
state it was very hard but when Maloney
shows up as the chef geez who's very
haunted by his past yeah that killed
that was one of the funniest through
lines of the movie for me we had no
place being
or we couldn't win geez
yeah well I'm gonna go smooth some mud
on my ass
what
I said I hear my
buds in class I gotta go I had no idea
that David Hyde Pierce was in this and I
had no idea that David Hyde Pierce and
Janine garofalo's relationship would
arguably steal a lot of those romance
scenes and Janine Garofalo is probably
my favorite performance now you could
wake up on any given day and say oh no
now this is my favorite part of what
happened now but Janine Garofalo the way
she delivers lines whether she's going
over the top and playing with the
spoofiness of it if she's just going
nutso like her and Joe with trugio
towards the end when they're just
wrecking everything trying to find a
phone but she can also just like play it
normal and play it straight and and
knock that out of the park she blew me
away in this movie honestly if they
redid this I would love to see Aubry
Plaza in a very similar oh yeah just
because like I really feel like she took
the Aubry Plaza energy to this one
anyway my whole point is with that
stacked of a cast in my personal opinion
think about it this way all you have to
do is give them a premise and say action
right that is the sole job of the
director slash writer on this what did
you do other than that to make this
elevated other than maybe all the
premises I understand Sky Labs falling
so you gotta stop it so we talk about
stuff talk about this movie it's almost
like yeah it's sort of like again what
we were talking about with two Leslie
well if your social group is a group of
the greatest comedy Minds you doing a
student film with them is not the same
so you you should I in my personal
opinion with the amount of talent that
got there I feel bad for everyone
involved because it should have been
better here's where it feels better I I
understand your point but I feel like
sense in the time that has passed since
this movie came out we've seen examples
of sort of like normal comedies that
were clearly made just because like that
couple's Vacation movie or whatever oh
yeah that's a movie that's made simply
so you can hang out with your friends on
a nice Island same thing with with at
least one of those ocean sequels okay
and those are terrible
what about the grown-ups yeah
hey this is funny
I just can't say that it is it is is a
positive movie I can't even give it that
umph because in honesty I if this was
the same movie with some nobodies I'd be
like okay I get it but it's almost like
what else would you do of course it's
gonna be funny these people would fall
down funny like there's nothing about
them I don't know I think I get that you
gotta grade it on a curve a little bit
but I think there there's a there's a
lot there's a lot did you see all these
those all those people get moments to be
really funny and they are but then don't
you say to yourself okay that makes this
a pretty average movie given the talents
that you had on screen I don't I don't
do like I don't I don't feel like I go
into movies like okay well this has got
five celebrity shows I like that it's
more B maximum unless you really blow me
away
on this podcast
as far as the directing of this movie
goes I think the big accomplishment from
David Wayne as a director of this movie
it wasn't necessarily in making one
cohesive story but you take all these
personalities even before they got huge
and I feel like I got the perfect
sampling I feel like I went to Golden
Corral with this movie and I got just
the same amount of fried chicken as I
did mac and cheese as I did dessert as I
did bread as I did vegetables like
everything it was very well balanced
they're so good this the editor is
really good he's like one of the best
parts of the movie because he had to
edit down a lot of this nonsense but I
and I traditionally love good spoof
movies but I have horror bad spoof
movies and this came out right around
the time when I I never really got into
the scary movies as much I can actually
appreciate them more in retrospect than
I can your meet the Spartans of the
world right and just the bad spoof
movies so this is even more of a light
than it should have been because if this
comes out in the in the era where we're
getting a top secret in 84 getting naked
gun 87 then I think it's another really
good spoof movie but the fact that it
came out as recently as it did impresses
me they're they're doing what the best
spoof movies do which is where they
really try as closely as possible to
sort of nail the vibe and the aesthetic
and the style of the thing that's being
parody like I think that's what Lonely
Island does so well very true as well
right star is really good drama is a
really good director like that's a great
example thank you pop star look at how
well they do that right because like in
pop star what Lonely Island is so good
at if they're making fun of like a
Justin Bieber video they're gonna copy a
Justin Bieber video and you're gonna
recognize the elements that Define a
Justin Bieber video in their parody and
I think that's what Wayne also manages
to do pretty well and this is like it
feels like meatballs it feels like sleep
away camp I think it's not like
essentially aesthetically I think
aesthetically it does but it doesn't
have the same Vibe I'll give you this
pop star feels like the same way you do
when you watch the Justin Bieber movie
of that you get the inside peek of this
person's parts of it or comedic or
laughable or fun but there's also like
that other side that's darker and then
there's like like literally like Katy
Perry what was her movie this is me now
or something
the Katy Perry documentary
almost through it right like she really
said Brad breaks up with her by attacks
but that's why pot star works so well
because it's exactly like watching one
of those like it reminds you of it and
walk Hard is another great example
I've heard so much like walk the line
that you like that's what makes it funny
this is the problem I have with wet Hot
American Summer it feels like a sketch
that wants to be within this but it
doesn't feel like it actually wants to
be a movie that plays the same way that
these hangout movies play I'm just
saying you know it's funny it's so great
okay can you compare this then to
something more like I would say along
the lines of Anchorman which Believe It
or Not plays it more straight than this
movie does or at least it's focused on
one storyline a lot more than anything
else then you have a lot of contributary
players but Ron burgundy's world is more
consistent right in the world Anchorman
is the same kind of movie like this and
that that goes back to my Super Bowl
party but there's a lot of more
connective tissue
a better movie but it's hard for me to
sit down and watch Anchorman start to
finish as much as I love it I can't
watch the whole movie in one sitting I
feel like wet Hot American Summer so
doesn't care about itself in that way
that even Anchorman does that it's so
Breezy that you can just kind of put it
on as the background right I think that
the what spoof movie's like this or what
particularly Wet Hot American Summer
gets away with why we give it a pass is
that we know that it's mocking something
and we know that it's making fun of
itself so if there is something in there
that comes out that appears to be
problematic or just doesn't work from a
comedic standpoint or just wasn't well
executed you can always just well that's
part of the joke this movie made a great
extended sketch
the other ones made great movies and
that's the difference this one wanted to
make a great extended sketch with
Incredible set pieces but it's not a
movie do you feel like if there is one
through on let's just take the David
Hyde Pierce Gene Garofalo relationship
what if that was the one thing that
we're rooting for then you have all
these other little tributary things that
don't equal the screen time but we're
focused on that story and how everybody
else is affected by it is that more what
you're talking about where it's just
like sticking to one story and telling
it well because I don't need that in
there I don't need this in this movie
either I think it's just a matter right
burgundy isn't telling a great story
well it's just front burgundy finding a
soul you know what I mean like it's a
very simple character Arc I don't need a
ton to get me to get me there with these
films but with this one there was very
little and the one thing I will say to
you and I do stand by this I know what
they were trying to create and they did
they created an incredible extended
sketch they did and they killed it and
like there are certain sort of like
jokes or premises or films like that
that work on that level but I feel like
they almost mixed the mediums it's like
either you want to have a movie like a
Walk Hard or a pop star or you want to
just make this a straight like Team
America hard pair you know what I mean
like like really go even broader it's
almost like I felt like they were trying
to be in and out on realism in a way
that didn't serve the actual story I
think there's one other thing I would
say I agree with with a lot of what
you're saying I think the one other
thing I would add is I think part of it
is Walk Hard there's is such an obvious
like it's it's the musical biopic like
we all know there's like a very clear
here's the genre and I think what out of
everything is kind of straddling there's
the camp comedy the the meatballs yes
stuff but then it's kind of also uh one
of those like Friday the 13th Camp
slasher films just without the slasher
exactly like Ken Marino's character I
think he said Vic Victor whatever he's
actually playing a guy from Sleepaway
Camp like he just he's dressing exactly
the same and he's acting exactly the
same and he like watched that guy's
performance it is mimicking it and like
you can't so it couldn't go scene by
scene and recreate Sleepaway Camp
because that would be awful and none of
us want to see that again it really is
almost like each little relationship in
this movie gets to do it different to
your point make a difference a little
bit of a sampler we also have that
Disaster Movie parody with with space
lab there's a comet that could hit Earth
and then we also have these little
rivalries we have people just trying to
make out with some we have somebody
who's got puppy love or somebody else
advanced stuff about exploring your you
know who you are and what kind of person
you want to be like there's a lot of
genres are sort of feeding in and that's
the problem I have with it like because
they put so much into it it makes it
great and for what it is but it doesn't
make it a movie this is a bully base and
that's dope but I would rather just had
a good chicken noodle like give me what
you're gonna give me well instead of
just I think throwing too many all right
so quick side note I have been Obsessed
the last couple weeks with the Great
British Bake Off sure I have been going
nuts binging this and I started with the
current season I've been going back and
they're they're all great but I I love
Paul and Prue as judges because this is
the kind of stuff you're talking about
where these are basically amateur Bakers
who hope to want to have occurred many
of them from the Great British Bake Off
have gone on to like launch their own
successful platforms but at heart
they're amateurs and so they're trying
to impress these two judges and a lot of
times the trouble they run into is
they're like okay well what's your show
stopper and it's like this cake with
nine different moving parts and it's
like you can't possibly get all of these
nailed in four hours so just because
comes something that's a little it's a
little less and that's what I'm hearing
is that you just tried to cram too much
into this pot pie Great British Bake Off
that was a great walk to get there I
love that right really like you really
hit the nail I thought you'd be happy
that I didn't do another Sports
reference no I
I said Great British Bake Off
the food show with a sports or gbbs I
mean honestly as in my age I've become a
person that is happy with Simplicity and
routine it's comforting because the
world is weird enough
but that's why you put on a movie like
wet Hot American Summer and but by the
way this is not a meal I'm against but
don't tell me you're coming to Camp with
one and I no I don't know this is not a
meal that I did not enjoy this is not a
meal I didn't laugh at like legitimately
anytime Amy Poehler was on screen with
her just like too much with it I was
living for it but she's so good
it's not what it needs to be considering
all and again I just look at the
ingredients
you know what I mean and I'm like it
just it ain't there it could be and it's
great for what it was but it ain't that
it's an All-Star team but they know
they're just playing in an All-Star Game
and none of this matters exactly
not an All-Star team is playing in the
Super Bowl and this is for the world
championship this is just we're all
really good at this and we're just going
to put on an exhibition for the fans
really like stuff like that like I find
it refreshing that Paul Rudd just gets
to be sailing like you know what he can
do when he's acting and when he's really
like paying attention to telling a real
story and like he's great I like Paul
Redden in lots of things but it's fun to
just get to see him not have to worry
about it so here's something fresh yeah
it's fun it's not that's what I was
going to ask Juan to do because because
Jaclyn's done a great job on a t-shirt
I'm telling us why you can enjoy this
movie but you don't think it's fresh so
why does this movie as far as like a
critical take on it why do you think
this movie deserves to be fresh because
you're better at articulating these
things and you're the guests are going
to put all the pressure on you uh I mean
listen I to me it's about it's about the
consistence level of humor like a lot of
comedies are funny for a while and then
you got that 20 minutes where they got
to work out the plot and suddenly things
get very serious and it's not as much
fun uh it's very hard to make a comedy
that is consistently funny the whole way
through every scene has at least a few
jokes and like the jokes per minute
quotient I would say is even very high
with this movie and like that's not a
thing you see very often I think there's
a lot of things where it's like there's
three really funny sequences and then
you're kind of waiting around for the
rest of the movie to like get there and
I don't feel that way with wet Hot
American Summer or really a lot of David
way like they came together as the same
where it's like every scene has at least
one or two maybe not every joke maybe is
working but every scene has at least one
or two very funny moments and sometimes
small things that are gonna be memorable
or make you laugh we were talking about
how great Janine Garofalo is before
subscribe there's one moment where David
Pierce's is laying out for her the
dangers like it's coming and it's this
angle and she just responds all of a
sudden he's like well we might have a
problem with uh Scott and she goes oh my
God like really dratically like stares
off into the distance and it's such a
disaster movie moment like something you
may not have even realized people do in
disaster moves until you see her do it
and it's so there's so many
the first time tennis sing that back to
David Hyde Pierce when they first meet
yeah and she just you know
just brings up randomly yeah hey if you
if you'd want to come teach your kids
when you're just like you know I'm like
I'm already thinking about it great idea
if you came by the camp and
taught the campers about space
oh they'd love it I
I would be just I said no
and then there was one other one I was
gonna say uh the delinquent my schmodown
character was actually inspired by this
movie yeah the scene where Paul Rudd
he's sitting and he's finished his lunch
and he just goes knocks the lunch tray
off like he's a disaffected teen and he
knocks the lunch plane and Junior almost
walk about she goes well you got to pick
that up and he does the most labor like
I do love like he's giving you the
picture of what Fonzie would be like in
real life that's what I look
[Music]
I lift characters as I um you know Amy
Pollard's character reminds me of the
girl with the cardigan and Heather's at
the very beginning when they're doing
the lunchtime yeah like I can pick each
of archetypes out of various teen movies
and some horror movies some comedies
somewhere some of them cult classics and
everywhere in between but Paul Rudd's
character obviously in this one is just
one that sort of like stands out with
his like did he have the puka shells on
is this right he did yeah
I specifically like the puka shells the
look the attitude the bra like he is
just that guy in this and I I really do
love that he's become synonymous even
with this very small movie in his like
sort of like Pantheon of other things
that he's doing also yeah he's got
Ant-Man coming out this weekend
the 30 event coming out quantumania and
again like did you think that the guy
from again also Role Models Dave David
Wayne movie but also like the guy from
Clueless did you think he was going to
be a superhero movie with his own like
opening where like you know well you
didn't know what he was gonna be from
from close because he was just this nice
looking dude who was kind of like the
guy next door but you didn't know if he
could be as funny as it would require to
hang with the crew from Wet Hot American
Summer or the 40 year old virgin yeah
then he also obviously don't know that
somebody who's now we've established
okay we like you you're funny you may be
a vampire because you're so ageless yeah
can you be a superhero and he can pull
that off too also I do love that we're
talking about wet Hot American Summer
because Paul Rudd's anti-aging
techniques whatever they may be were on
full display in the sequel because that
was film like what 15 years after the
original and everybody else aged and not
great these are comedians who drank and
smoked and did all right
they play you know because they're
playing they don't they don't de-age
them at all they do no effort to make
them look younger they just have them
playing themselves at the same you know
Summer from Wet Hot American Summer and
Michael Showalter is hilarious yeah
became like a big guy yeah yeah and he's
just playing Coop the same same way
just because I I don't want to forget
this are gonna be my favorite character
in the entire movie is
the the host of the talent show that
we're going up to all day is a Michael
Showalter character and it's just this
old like cat skills comedus like what
the hell is this guy doing here diesel
Inception yeah you're watching it and
every time I see it there's a little
tension of oh my God that's the Ghost of
Christmas future but it also reminded me
after Saturday night
it was a very tough movie for Comics to
watch and where it's Billy Crystal like
90 still doing like like jokes at a
bowling alley and you're like this poor
guy just got a gig but it's so funny and
it was heartwarming to see he's got
another oh hard he's killing in this
little room in the middle of nowhere but
he's murdering yeah he's got another one
of those like little tiny almost not
even a joke jokes that's so memorable
when he called they do they're doing day
by day from Godspell one of my favorite
Broadway numbers day
I don't know why I didn't pronouncing it
like that is so funny oh I didn't get
that I just thought it was like uh
oh my gosh I didn't even get it if I can
ask you and Jacqueline if you've seen it
too because given my lack of expertise
on this movie and what it's created
since then I was talking to producer
Brian and he's like no I think the the
sequel was it was a TV series
Netflix eight episode series spin-offs
yeah series how do we feel about this
there's a prequel in a sequel yeah well
what is the first day of camp which goes
to the the first day of this Summer that
we see we see the last day of camp in
wet Hot American Summer yeah so the
first Netflix show is a prequel that
shows them all arriving to begin the
stats and it was filmed when they were
wailed so they're all just they're all
just old playing themselves as high
schoolers uh and then the next one is
ten years later and we see a full
dramatization of them meeting up again
10 years later to like talk about their
lives and how do we feel about these did
they live up to it I think they're great
I mean it's it's not the same experience
because like we were saying with the
with the with the movie it's like joke a
minute it's not really a story it's just
coming at you these they they try to
make them more of like a show and so
it's more there's rise and fall and plot
lines or whatever so if that sounds good
to you it might sound good to Jacqueline
I was just about to say
um the limitations yeah are are apparent
and some of them yes the limitations to
their storytelling did not like the week
weakness that they were maybe papering
over in this first one was not something
they fortified as they made it linear it
was still in my opinion pretty flimsy
it's very it's the same sense of gleeful
absurdity yeah nothing has to really
link up nothing has to make logical
sense but they are fleshing it out more
and like putting a lot more and this one
it seems like it did and I will go go
back and watch these just again because
I enjoy the Creator so much they were
better received I mean that like there
were a lot of Wet Hot American Summer
fans already including among critics by
the time these came out so yeah there
was a more receptive ground people just
know if this is a thing for me I think
it's also fun to see we also see how
famous some of these people become and
so it's like oh my God I can't believe
yeah they all they'll come back and then
the Paul wrote of it all he looked the
same he like he legit like he's now I
study him now because first of all I
study any white person that Rivals black
people's skin because personally as
somebody that lives with somebody that
it irritates he's older than me he's
older he's got he's got good uh he's got
he's got good genes he's just it's it's
infuriating I feel like he's getting
better I feel like he and Tom Cruise are
both like they're right at this point
where it is starting it is just in the
last few like months like six months
they're actually beginning to look like
human people and it never used to happen
no like you would see Tom Cruise years
apart you'd be like still looks but this
one with that same bad wig take one take
two yeah you don't even see a difference
and that ladies and gentlemen is why you
should go see quantumania because he's
finally become finally becoming human
he's finally becoming a trip to the
quantum realm but it's finally wrinkle
for your sanity I appreciate it for you
anyway that's kind of wrapping I can't
imagine what being shrunk and then re
and then going huge and then coming back
I can't imagine what that does to your
skin is I mean honestly I really hope
he's investing in moisturizer because he
should anyway that's it for us on movie
talk we're gonna go ahead and transition
over into our mailbag
how y'all doing to our ketchup crew
member damrus Ortiz dear Mark and
Jacqueline please talk about Along Came
Polly this movie is criminally
underrated is hilarious all the way
through with multiple laugh out loud
moments the movie isn't perfect but it's
really nice to see a rom-com pull off
being sweet while not taking it to self
too seriously it is infinitely watchable
best Damaris Ortiz dying to know what
Jaclyn thought of the Avatar sequel P.S
I love this I've keep my opinions to
myself
um
let me just say this about Avatar real
quick
um this is what's weird I like Avatar
unironically I just do I I like the
world I don't put too much thought
behind it I just like James Cameron b
and James Cameron doing James Cameron
things and I was in on on the world more
thanks to this movie than I was the
first one let's talk about Along Comes
Along Came Polly because this is one of
those ones this is another one of these
manic pissy Dream Girls probably just a
hot girl with autism stories from that
time period like Julia Styles and we
really understood autism we thought they
were just legitimately
was our understanding literally too many
Tick Tock videos you take all the
symptoms of autism and you put them up
against all these manic pixie Dream
Girls and it's basically like oh it's a
hot girl with autism that's it
that's why she's a manic pixie dream
girl she doesn't like sweaters no she
has sensory issues for Ben Stiller and
this has uh Philip Seymour Hoffman and I
was gonna say that the real like oh look
it's fine scene stealer but it does
feature an amazing amazing comedic
performance from from the greatest him
playing basketball with the sweat but it
tells it doesn't really
at some point that's awesome there's a
lot of body function humor there's the
the chest terrorists that we're just
sliding down a dude's chest but it's
also just watching Philip Seymour
Hoffman and he's I mean I'm sure he
could actually shoot in real life better
than this right but his shot in the
movie he's so laughable
yeah
he's like yeah so great at least again
Philip Seymour Hoffman it's so sad
way to go we definitely need to get this
one on here lawn sir it was great having
you again oh I might add that all of our
guests bring a certain Vibe but you
always bring and I I say this is a
compliment A professorial vibe to
everything that you do there's a little
bit of a delinquency under the professor
I know from experience I didn't say that
you were like not like the Berkeley
Stone Professor that is normally late 10
times you know and I'm not saying that
you're like that guy but he's the tenure
Professor who's selling to the kids
I'm sadly just an assistant professor
exactly you know but the tenure yet but
we always learn something when you're
here and so before we get out of here
tell us what you're working on before I
make this any worse of an accident oh
well everybody should definitely check
out my uh podcast I do every week with
Hal Rudnick it's called binge boys yeah
we just talk about whatever we're
watching on streaming platforms and it
gets a little heated sometimes more than
more than this this is very competitive
Phil Hoffman levels their tastes are not
similar in a lot of ways they are
sometimes but then sometimes well we
it's everything movies too like we I
really yelled at him about banshees of
industry and I felt bad I was like I
should call how you don't like it I
didn't it wasn't even that I hated it I
just didn't like it as much as most
people yeah well you were like ready to
do you all need a therapy do you all
need a therapist
s that some
that summer party I've had that
experience for this like I've done
podcasts in the past like way in the
distant past where it's like afterwards
was like I should probably call them but
yeah I've never had to call each other
every once in a while we've gone out but
we've never had to cut we've never had
to have the phone call I will say
without question I hope anybody else
would this is you are by far the most
productive and non-drama relationship
I've ever had with an adult man uh oh
I'm getting a phone call after this
episode
I really cherished it in that also lawn
since you do watch every week and go on
the binge boys podcast to talk about I'm
sure you've got some great new shows or
something or a movie that you want to
recommend to folks to check out yeah I
haven't yet I uh the the best thing I've
watched I think oh yeah I mean I'm
really enjoying the last of us but the
other best thing I've watched all your
coping and Hagen or Copenhagen
Copenhagen cowboy on Netflix the
Nicholas winding reference show oh yeah
crazy I mean if you have to like his
weird stuff like if you're not into neon
demon or only God forgives or drive even
like if you like that stuff and he did
that Amazon Prime video show uh too well
to Die Young with Miles Teller that I
also liked if you're into his stuff it's
awesome it's super atmospheric very cool
very weird surreal lots of great action
it's very cool like characters and it's
set in this very intricate sort of
Nicholas winding refund he's making his
own world now like Wes Anderson where
yeah it's just like this this crazy
little I'm very hit or miss with that
guy there's some things where I'm just
like blown away and then there's others
where I'm like this is just not for me
you gotta give over to her like it's a
little bit slow it's a lot of synth and
neon and like what he does but I really
I really loved it that's on Netflix well
we can all ratify the last of us okay
that's much safer if you if you like the
games oh my God look at him he's like no
I'm good I'm trying to elevate here I'm
trying to go higher level at higher
level it's just it's like weird and it's
the kind of thing I'm hesitant to
recommend to people because sometimes
they'll watch it and be like what the
hell well that's just the type of
recommendation
it's from you yes it's not from it's
from Moana it's from lawn all right well
on thank you so much for joining us
again so this week I want to let
everyone know you can be like Damaris
and email us at RT is wrong with rotten
tomatoes.com and let us know what you
think we should cover next she did
incred or they did an incredible Choice
with Along Came Polly I don't want to
gender you one way or the other but
wherever you're listening to this anyone
please rate review And subscribe do it
share it with your friends let everyone
know that they can listen to us debate
about the merits of Paul Rudd's aging
and wet Hot American Summer
in general moisturize I I hope it's that
I really hope it's that all right that's
it for us this week on Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong a big thanks Mr Brian Perez Our
Guest this week lawn Harris of course
Tim Ryan are two minutes with Tim I'm
Jacqueline Coley this is Mark Ellis and
we will see you all next time
[Music]